we got the first and second most
important men in the world meeting today
who's who
well Xi Jinping and and Donald Trump
have had very icy start since the
election of Donald Trump and as we
remember there were lots of anti China
rhetoric particularly even before the
election and on the campaign trail now
we see a much warmer relationship not
only Donald Trump it's the first
American president to be invited and
welcomed within Forbidden City this is
very much the first time any Chinese
Chinese leader had offered that honor to
a foreign leader and when we talk about
trade America putting American first
what Donald Trump did almost as amazing
diplomatic triumph as few days before he
arrived to China FAA approved the air
worthiness of Chinese aircraft
manufacturers so now the China Chinese
aircrafts and parts will be able to be
sold within the US as well as to other
countries around around the world that
is something extremely significant on
the trade side that's something China
has wanted for a long time it's a
milestone to have that approved well we
can bring in now Richard McGregor he's
former Washington bureau chief for the
Financial Times and author of a new book
Asia's reckoning China Japan and the
fate of us power in the Pacific so
Richard Diane just talking us through
some of the trade deals that have been
struck today they aren't going to make
any meaningful difference to the trade
imbalances between America and China
there are they not no they're not I mean
this is mr. Trump is obsessed with the
bilateral trade balance and that's never
really going to come down because the
Chinese bilateral trade balance with
America is really a part of a regional
imbalance with the US so just
concentrating on the bilateral imbalance
won't make much difference so I don't
think there's any really great progress
on the trade issue at all today our
Donald Trump's made some pretty
blood-curdling threats to China in the
past threatening retaliation against
China if they don't mend their ways in
terms of trade practices do you think
he's going to rein back on those whereas
that threat still live Richard I think
that threat is still live we don't know
what's going to happen but the US has a
number of cases those filed with the
World Trade Organization which would
allow them to retaliate I think you know
this is going to play out over a lengthy
number of years the u.s. really has not
got all its ducks in a row yet on the
trade issue to allow it to push back
against China what we're seeing now is
symbolic action to placate mr. Trump but
I think it's got a long way to go yet
Diane do you think that Donald Trump may
soften some of his trade demands if mr.
ji agrees to help him out in terms of
reining in North Korea Donald Trump has
already changed his tones from the time
that he went into the White House and
the relationship is much warmer now and
if we look at a political relationship
we'll see that spill over to trade I'm
sure trade will be a big topic in China
however there is North Korea issue
there's also the political bilateral
relationship between the two so the
first and second largest economy in the
world and we've heard a lot less of anti
China rhetoric from the camp the Donald
Trump camp and I believe that trade will
be a topic but the tone will be much
more cooperative all right Richard
previous presidential visits to China
have invariably involved visits to human
rights leaders mr. Trump isn't doing
that now he's not I think there's a
couple of things to say on that I don't
think he's particularly interested in
the issue it's not high on his personal
agenda and I think over time of course
the US has taken human rights has been
less front and center of the
relationship largely in many respects
because the US has little leverage on
the issue they didn't have much leverage
when there are a much more powerful
country than China they probably have
even less leverage now and I think that
explains the absence of that on this
trip so far all right Richard McGregor
in Washington dime whaling here in
London thanks both for joining me